hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
party yeah we're following the sun we're
still in california now we're in palm
springs
thanks to something stacy's been cooking
up maybe she'll talk about it i don't
know
what do i know stacy yes we're here at
the first
the inaugural crypto springs conference
and it's been amazing we've had so many
this is literally the best crypto
conference
that i've ever attended and i'm the
organizer i know so i could be by full
disclosure
i organized this event but it was uh
it's been quite amazing and i've learned
so much and
there will be a lot of the um the
various talks will be available online
so you can go online and go look at this
uh
just google crypto springs and you'll
find some of the stories
but um you know i wanted to look at a
few uh items that have been
used mostly trump driven in the past few
days while we've been here in palm
springs and
like close to 100 degree temperature and
very dry
first this actually doesn't have
anything to do with trump but it's going
to lead into a
headline about him this is a tweet from
the national weather service in los
angeles and it's the end of the ward
water year all right well i'm saying
like a new worker
i don't know what your problem is babe
but you need to spit it out there
because we don't have all day you know
what i'm saying just get it out
so the end of the water year was october
1st 2017
to september 30th 2018 precipitation
summary
and um on the colored chart that you'll
see on full screen
you can see we are way down below very
very
parched conditions in california this
year
due to some might say the next headline
trump administration sees a seven degree
rise
in global temperatures by 2100.
last month deep in a 500 page
environmental impact statement
the trump administration made a
startling assumption
on its current course the planet will
warm a disaster
seven degrees by the end of the century
so this of course is way worse than what
scientists are even saying but
here the trump administration buried in
this 500 page report
made this assumption that actually they
believe that temperatures will rise by 7
degrees
but the administration did not offer
this as a dire forecast
premise on the idea that the world will
fail to cut its greenhouse gas emissions
as part of an argument to combat climate
change just the opposite
this analysis assumes the planet's fate
is already sealed
and that we should therefore get rid of
fuel emission standards and other sort
of
uh carbon emissions standards let's
party on you know why
try to give up the alcohol if you're an
alcoholic
if you know that there's going to be
free booze your whole life
you know this is obviously a case of
denial denial denial
especially in that republican side the
energy side the funders who
who've been supporting the climate
denial industry
out there for years that there's no such
thing as climate change or
planet's not getting hotter the planet's
actually getting cooler
and and we see we've been battling these
people for years
and now suddenly they flipped and said
well
you know we were lying to you uh we were
enabling this whole thing to happen
rachel carson was right greenpeace was
right
uh we are facing an extinction event uh
but it's okay
because we are throwing the biggest end
of species party
the extinction party it's going to be
great you're going to love it it'll be a
trump hotel
and of course you know i've said and
i'll say what quickly once again
there's a huge industry for wrongful
birth insurance anyone born
now your parents now cannot deny that
they know
that there's less than one lifetime's
worth of ecological resources for you
you can sue them for wrongful birth okay
absolutely you need wrongful birth
insurance it's a billion dollar industry
tell warren buffett this is his next way
to screw everybody
in fact there was an article uh that was
tweeted out by the wall street journal
and they were talking about the fact
that
insurers are having a hard time
basically um there's so many one in a
thousand year events that they're having
to increase
uh they're being hit hard by climate
change disasters
and so they're increasing their um their
their premiums
but the fact is you know i tweeted back
at wall street journal saying well
isn't your editorial page like
responsible for all sorts of climate
change denial that you're pushing
so um in a way i i do agree with them
that it's too late
it's way too late now i think there's
nothing that we could do to stop the
catastrophes that are coming because the
catastrophes are already happening
i mean while we've been here by the way
my stepfather had to he was ordered by
fema to leave his house
i received an emergency text from fema
around the same time it had nothing to
do with it but the fact is he was
ordered by fema
because of the hurricane that hit north
carolina there's a giant sinkhole
opening behind his house and is going to
eat his house
so he's been ordered by climate
catastrophe my stepfather is
a climate change refugee right now right
he has no home
millions more yeah hundreds of millions
of more it's like the black plague of
the
1400s and society was broken into two
camps those who were self-flagellating
because they blamed themselves and those
who went on a fornication madness
you know just like the end of the world
let's get it on
so there's just orgies in the street
everywhere and so flagellators so that i
think the next two or three years that
we'll see the same
kind of uh societal break you'll see
orgies and self-flagellators
okay well that kind of takes me to the
next headline
based on what i've seen in london
regarding the saudi royal family
kind of looks like some of that
flagellation you're talking about
but trump says saudi king wouldn't last
two weeks without us help president
donald trump said the king of saudi
arabia
may not last two weeks without u.s
support escalating pressure
on one of his closest arab allies to
curb rising oil prices and pay for
military protection
quote how about our military deals where
we protect rich nations that we don't
get reimbursed
trump told a campaign rally in the u.s
state of mississippi last week
i love the king king salman but i said
king we're protecting you
you might not be there for two weeks
without us you have to pay for your
military
you have to pay you have to pay for us
yeah yeah yeah i love the king i love
the magic ball we put our hands on the
magic lawn
the orb it was great the king had a
great dinner at the king it was
fantastic i love the king
but we're going to have to get rid of
him because he's not good listen this
fits into phil you know my theory going
about trump is that
he sees the balance sheet of america the
pentagon the military budget is too rich
he's already de-escalating tensions on
the korean peninsula so that we are now
peninsula so now now uh kim jong-un is
his best friend
and we're going to pull troops out of
south korea he's said nato is is garbage
we're going to pull troops out of
germany that pushes germany into the
arms of russia by the way
and now he's in the middle east saying
to the saudi king we're pulling all of
our troops out of the saudi arabia as
well
because trump is a man of peace
yeah he's he's quite a piece that's what
one can say
so oil prices have risen to 80 or close
to 80
a barrel and um trump is not happy with
it so
the funny thing is is i have another
headline also from bloomberg and it was
like
a few days before this headline of trump
threatening the
saudi king and that is what oil at one
hundred dollars a barrel
would mean for the global economy i
think they have to
rewrite that because obviously um the
saudi king looks like he would be
headless i think the people of saudi
arabia would be able to go after him
perhaps
if the u.s does not protect the royal
family there but well i'm sure he's got
one major dissenter and
the billionaire in the saudi who they
kept cooped up in a hotel and the reds
for
weeks and he had to give a lot of his
wells back prince
prince ali we tell out he's probably
working with trump right now to
overthrow
the king of saudi arabia a bit of a coup
in the horizon
you know why not well there was actually
an interesting bit in this
story about the 100 per barrel oil
um of course it wouldn't be good for
consumer nations they point out
but uh because of fracking and because
of fuel efficiency
standards that uh you know it might not
be as bad as the last time in 2007
2008 but they point out that most of the
big oil producing nations would do well
obviously and their emerging economy
saudi arabia
leads the way with a net oil production
that is almost
21 of gross domestic product as of 2016
which is more than twice that of russia
which is the next among 15
major emerging markets in oil producers
so 21 of gdp
for saudi arabia is oil and energy
production
in russia they're saying it's like 10 so
again i want to point out that in
america it's something like 18
of our economy is just health care so we
are a hospital masquerading
as a nation if that you know what dick
cheney had said about russia was that
they're a
gas station masquerading as a nation so
just to put into context
well the ability to keep inflation genie
and the bottle is evaporating so we see
prices going up across the board oil is
just one of them we see interest rates
rising that's inflationary
we see the dollar eventually cracking
and having catastrophic collapse that's
usually inflationary
so prices across the board go up that
makes that russia
saudi arabia venezuela hello uh they're
oil-based economies they all benefit
wildly from this
the emerging market takes the benefit of
this and
oil and gold gold starting to perk up
again and bitcoin of course would
skyrocket to a hundred thousand plus
and then just speaking of russia i have
this last headline and you know we just
left hollywood we're out here in palm
springs and this is such a crazy
headline i
genuinely genuinely thought this was
like from the onion one of those
satirical news sites
and it's so it's real and it's it's
disturbing
star wars the last jedi negative buzz
amplified by russian trolls study fines
so an
academic paper released titled
weaponizing the haters the last jedi and
the strategic politicization of pop
culture through social media
manipulation
examines the online response of 2017's
last jedi a movie that has come to be
considered
controversial amongst his larger fan
base of the franchise
but the study suggests that reputation
may not be earned
that instead they find the study finds
that evidence of deliberate organized
political influence measures disguised
as fan
arguments is the likely objective of
these measures
is increasing media coverage of the
fandom conflict thereby adding to
and further propagating a narrative of
widespread discord
and dysfunction in american society
right that's like saying that
russia and the soviet union were
responsible for lynching blacks in the
south
uh during the past 200 years because in
these new star wars films they feature a
black character
and they are being attacked by the
alt-right and the extreme right and the
racists in america
and to justify this in hollywood because
they don't want to admit the level of
racism in america
they blame it on russia that's so
freaking pathetic the news media is
hollywood is and the social discourse in
america is
it's sad it's just a freaking movie
about aliens in furry costumes shooting
each other with ray guns
get over yourself america yeah but i
mean you saw
this sort of thing at the hollywood
stock exchange when you ran that in
terms of the inputs and your algorithm
to determine prices on various box
office features
uh how would you input this into your
algorithm well
at that time there was 98 of the
internet was white so anything with a
black
actor or director attached it took less
buy orders to move it up in price so
that's part of the algorithm that i
developed is patented 5950176 is the
patent number if you want to look it up
and so you need to make certain
concessions toward the demographic and
psychographic of the
market to make a fair market with price
parity but
that is a way to adjust for racism so
it's racism adjusted
prices need to be racism adjusted just
like the price for exxon mobil stock
needs to be adjusted for their risk
the risk of the extinction event that
they're perpetuating that risk adjusted
price for exxon mobil stock is zero
the risk adjusted price for monsanto now
owned by bear
is zero the risk adjusted price for
apple and
microsoft is zero well we gotta take a
break uh we'll be right back after this
uh don't go away
[Music]
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max keiser time now to turn
to shira frank who i've just met
shira welcome to the kaiser report thank
you so we're here at the crypto springs
in palm springs it's attracting an
international crowd
a diverse crowd talented crowd
technologist and in your case
a lobbyist in washington for j street is
that correct i have that correct so far
yeah i was a lobbyist i was an organizer
i was a fundraiser so tell us a little
bit more about that organization just to
kick this off
sure i think it's really important and
thanks for asking a question outside of
crypto
because i think we uh we need more of
that so i worked for j street for eight
years
um j street looked at the u.s israel
relationship
and said you know what i think
something's wrong here i don't think
we're actually serving
israel's best interests the palestinians
best interests and certainly not the u.s
and they tried to figure out what was
wrong and they realized there was this
huge effort
to convince the u.s government that to
be pro-israel
meant to do whatever the israeli
government said
when in fact often the israeli
government might be doing something that
was counter
to israel's sustainability or survival i
mean it's a democratic country you can
elect a super far right wing or super
far left wing or
whatever have it and that government may
or may not be doing what's best for
israel so in washington dc that's been
dominated by one lobbying group you got
it
apac the american israeli political
action committee
in fact aipac doesn't stand for that
okay which is
good to know so aipac stands for the
american israel public
affairs committee so that was how j
street actually got its edge
is we won by having the largest
pro-israel pac the
political action committee and we
realized that aipac
by the way apec donors do contribute to
candidates and that's how they
were effective but the organization
didn't as a whole
and so you couldn't trace where were the
dollars going if you were like well how
much
you know how much money do you get from
apac well a pack should not pack we
don't
you know and so what we found out is we
could convince senators
and congress people over time and it was
not that long only eight years and apac
is
decades old and hundred million plus
dollars
but with an eight million dollar budget
and really good community organizing and
incredibly strategic messaging
we were able to convince enough senators
and members of congress that to be
pro-israel
is to be pro-palestinian to be
pro-israel is to be pro-peace
you know this narrative in terms of
israel and palestine
it's a narrative that we grew up with
yeah um and and there's certain
uh heroes and villains in the story and
um to question it
brought about a wrath of of media
attention
and a lot of negativity um so
that story that official story you're
saying needs some nuance
needs a little context you should have
been our comms director yeah
exactly nuance and so actually when we
first started out in year one
we thought we only had to change the
political money flow
and we quickly realized that members of
congress go home and guess what happens
when they go home to their home district
they get the wrath of the rabbi who has
the wrath of the community who has the
wrath of there's only one way to be
pro-israel and it's just to say yes
to whatever israel does so we actually
had to change the whole communal
cultural narrative and so we had to
launch
organizing and we had to launch student
movements and we had to actually change
how people understood the conversation
that they could say you know what it's a
little bit more complicated or
it's not black and white and even just
being okay with asking a question
okay so now we've established the the
kind of the the
the the set the table sure so let me ask
you a question you know about
mid-east politics oh wow yeah i see what
you think of it so um
as i understand it um in the subject of
iran
uh in the case of iran you've got uh the
hardliners let's call it apac
has a certain position yeah which is
very aggressive toward around
and i understand that j street has a
different position
and this is playing out now in real time
and has real
world consequences so in other words in
the case of iran
um what they've said to donald trump is
you know you need to tweet less
uh because uh this pulling out of this
deal as you've done
has you know there's a lot of oil prices
going up and trump is saying we don't
like oil prices going up
and so that's okay so from 30 000 feet
above looking down
talk a little bit about that give your
perspective if you can absolutely and i
think that's a lot of what brought me
into crypto oddly enough so
i'll try to tie those together if i can
just to start where you began which is
what the hell is going on
with the us and israel and iran like
what is going on here and
um the iran nuclear deal which obama
was able to push through and j street
was the lead lobbyist to get that
through congress so even though the
state department and hillary clinton and
then carry
you know in this decade you know long
time of actually
a diplomatic agreement with iran and i
think it's important to remember we went
to war with who
iraq remember when that happened and
right okay so j street didn't exist
at that time right the the pro-diplomacy
way
of of working and with the political
dynamics of israel being anti-muslim i
mean
it didn't exist so we were able to push
a diplomatic deal through but then trump
comes into office
so even with all that power and
intensity and intelligence and political
change
um it still didn't matter because regime
change in this country
meant the fraying of all of that and so
i think what that taught me
is that this has to politics isn't
enough even the best politics
we can't move money fast enough we can't
move power intelligently enough with
political systems
that it has to be something else and i
actually know what that was
you know until i found crypto and that's
where i saw holy cow these are different
kinds of systems
okay so in the case of iran they were
subjected to monetary censorship
the swift monetary movement system huge
things was
was sanctioned and said this is a weapon
that the us uses against
folks that they don't agree with they
interfere
in a lot of uh activities going abroad
so crypto to segway into crypto
crypto is is censorship resistant right
and so you're saying that beyond the
political solutions
there needs to be something more
something more substantive
yeah and that leads to crypto so that
take us take us there
when people say what's the toughest
problem i mean middle east peace comes
up
or the middle east comes up right and
here i had in my personal experience in
my like 24 7 job for eight years
seen that you could achieve
extraordinary change you could not go to
war with iran like we went to war with
iraq you could do these things and yet
and yet it could be frayed so
easily so even the hardest challenges
you could solve
intelligently with political systems and
power jockeying and moving money
the way we were doing in politics but
then it could fray so quickly so i think
with crypto the question is could this
be
a way to organize power and we don't use
that term enough in crypto
i mean in politics it's about power no
one ever you know but in crypto we're
like oh well it's about decentralization
well decentralization of what
power right and so i think where i hope
we're going in crypto is that we
do decentralize power globally
effectively on a lot of different layers
and such that in in the case of iran
like
the sanctions that we and many other
countries in the u.s were imposing on
iran and the
what that meant for the people of iran
like let's we were talking about the
politics i mean there was extraordinary
suffering
for no reason these people were doing
absolutely nothing iran is incredibly
highly educated population
um these are people who we should be if
we care about democracy and i'm not
saying
we we must but if we are as american
saying we care about democracy these
were the mo
these would be partners in democracy
like iran is not the nation in the
middle east to be
vilifying um and yet what did we do we
created enemies out of the people of
iran
through these sanctions yeah strangely
enough the the country now in the
crosshairs will be saudi arabia
because trump is saying you know saudis
are responsible for this higher oil
price and
he's saying they're not going to be
around in two weeks the king of saudi
arabia
so iran is like you know breathing a
sigh of relief it's like that crazy man
in the white house has now set his
sights on
the saudis uh you know so he's causing
all kinds of
um dislocations of power power is
shifting
it's very mercurial yeah and it's
definitely not in the hands of the
people so if you believe in
democracy and you believe in distributed
power to the and it comes from the
ground up certainly we're not seeing
that uh but however
if i hear you correctly you're
suggesting that crypto
can bring us back to a place of
distributing
power yeah it has that potential i mean
i'll bring it to the human body in a way
and just
follow me if you will and tell me if it
doesn't make sense but you know your
left eye
takes in data and feeds it to your brain
from the world if your eyes are seeing
eyes
and your right eye takes some very
different data and feeds it to your
brain
um and that's how you get depth of field
that's how we get
intelligence what we have in the power
system of the planet is we've had very
few people
holding lots of power and a lot of whole
people holding
very little amounts of power and i think
we just need an intelligence of power
we need a distribution of power and i
don't know what that is going to look
like
exactly but i am really convinced it
will be more intelligent
it will be more resilient to power tend
to be in the central banks
the central banks have central power and
they control the fiat money and the
money is value based on their fear their
dictate their
theory it has no trade value it has no
a non-depreciating value it just it's
not worth anything
so it it so does crypto offer a hard
money solution
safe dean a moose who is in lebanon who
is let's say lebanon and israel are um
at loggerheads they are politically
completely on
opposite side uh he is a hard money
advocate
you know and he is someone who his dad
was in the palestinian
uh refugee camps and he's very aware of
the politics in the situation
and he believes hard money is a way to
distribute power and to
and to take it away from elements that
are anti-egalitarianism uh
you would you agree with that no
no why why would you think i would agree
money would you agree that hard money is
a way toward
bringing in a more distributed power
system by distributing hard money oh you
mean like redistributing fiat
like meaning that if crypto is hard
money oh
and you have individual stocks why do
you think crypto isn't hard i'm just a
little confused by you
why don't i think it that isn't hard
money what is hard money in your
definition
hard money is uh is the opposite of fiat
money if you have money
no intrinsic value it's paper money
money is like gold that has
exchange value okay okay now you're
following money got it and so
central banks are the purveyors of fiat
i love these languages see this is
why we need more people in politics and
media in crypto because
words really matter like hard money this
is actually i mean i
haven't been in crypto as long as you
but i would say that's not a term i
actually hear that often
right and i don't know that that's gonna
what does that connote but anyway to
answer your questions
um the transfer of value without
depreciation
right the problem with fiat so anyway
let's maybe just swing over toward
like into your wheelhouse so to speak
you suggested that
crypto could benefit from having some
lobbyists and taking on
this industry yeah and what you
succeeded with j street
you know crypto needs a political edge
yes it does
is and that's that's that antithema and
to most thinking but can it can you know
when you
mention politics in an event like this
is so talk on that we have about a
minute left
okay the politicians have crypto is a
lobbyist in washington
right well i think it's changing i think
it was antithetical
to the early days of crypto and bitcoin
the idea of politics and
lobbying and these and i think it's
still edgy and complex but i think that
if you are shapeshift or if you are
coinbase or if you are any of these
institutions i think shapeshift
especially with these deep values these
deep libertarian crypto
early bitcoin values you are seeing that
if you
want hard money to have its promise
realized
you're gonna have to communicate with
people you're gonna have to deal with
power dynamics
or even if you're into lobbying groups
in washington there's the bitcoin
lobbying group so where are they not
what are they not getting it's more than
just having a lobby in washington
it's having the intelligence of
political organizing in our industry
um operations so when you're a product
and you want to penetrate a market
and you're crypto it's not just
penetrating a market you're changing
power dynamics or you're attempting to
change power understanding and financial
understanding that's organizing there's
nothing else
and you need a comms team if you're a
campaign and you're running for office
what's the first person you hire money
okay fine crypto has money so they don't
need that
the second person you hire coms all
right i'm the last person
we got to wrap it up because we're on
time unfortunately doing another segment
at some point but for this today we
gotta say goodbye thanks for being on
the kaiser report
you're welcome thanks for having me all
righty and that's going to do it for
this edition of the kaiser report with
me max keiser and stacey here we want to
thank our special guest
shira frank do you want to catch us on
twitter it's kaiser report until next
time bye y'all
[Music]